This is Titan, Saturn’s largest moon.
Though it’s 800 million miles from our planet,
it’s actually one of the most Earth-like
places in the solar system with a topography
full of oceans and lakes.
And NASA has a crazy plan to send a space
submarine to explore it.
But we’ll come back to that.
Titan is larger in size than Mercury and is
the only world beyond Earth and Venus with
a dense atmosphere, which is why it’s often
dubbed Planet Wannabe.
Within its atmosphere are a curious assortment
of clouds, including some made of noxious
compounds like hydrogen cyanide and benzene
and monstrous ice clouds that form in its
south pole.
These help scientists investigate Titan’s
weather patterns, which could impact the landing
of a futuristic space sub.
Unlike Earth, Titan’s incredibly thick atmosphere
is actually full of nitrogen and methane instead
of oxygen, which creates its glow.
The orange haze kept Titan shrouded in mystery
for years, until NASA sent Cassini to peer
through it in 2004.
Cassini made more than 100 fly bys of Titan
and eventually sent a probe dubbed Huygens
onto its surface.
While en route, two imaging instruments collected
data and infrared photos of Titan’s surface,
which is what you’re looking at right now.
Huygens’ view gave NASA scientists their
first look at the mysterious moon.
And what got NASA really excited is that Cassini
and Huygens images revealed that Titan has
lakes and seas filled with hydrocarbons like
methane and ethane, instead of H2O.
These were the first leaks to be discovered
beyond Earth.
Even more curious, if life exists on Titan,
it could have a completely different biochemistry
than life on our planet.
Which means, methane based life forms.
Or life as we don’t know it.
And Titan’s cryogenic seas could hold clues
of life, so that’s why scientists are eager
to build a space sub for further exploration.
The latest blueprints include a sonar array,
meteorology sensor, a retractable sail, and
a hydrodynamic skin for the 6 meter long sub.
Plus cameras of course to take the best pictures
possible of what life is like underneath this
icy moon.
The plan is for the sub to explore an area
called the Kraken Mare, which is Titan's largest
northern sea.
As it swims through the Kraken, it’ll determine
the lake’s chemistry, its depths, and map
the seafloor.
But designing and constructing a submarine
that can survive at -300 degrees Fahrenheit
(-148 degrees Celsius) is a significant challenge
and one that quite frankly, might be completely
impossible.
And because Titan’s seas have concentrations
of ethane and methane, the liquid density
of the oceans and lakes could change, and
it could make it difficult for the sub to
propel through them.
If NASA manages to overcome all these challenges
and is able to construct a fully autonomous
submarine, it’ll still take seven years
before it reaches Titan.
But we’re still holding onto hope that we’ll
see this crazy mission launch even if we have
to wait several decades for it happen.
Make sure to follow Space Crafts to learn
all about astronomical events and phenomena!
And don’t forget to share with your friends.
Check out other episodes like this one about
water on Mars.
Let us know in the comments what space stories
you want to learn more about.
Thanks for watching!